Speaker 1: Donald Trump is also now reacting
not yet to Nikki Haley saying she's running.
But reacting to Ron DeSantis and Ron DeSantis
doing better than Trump in some recent polls
and Trump throwing an absolute and complete
tantrum on his platform.
Truth, Social truth, essential.
Donald Trump reacting to a report that he's
obsessed with the Santas and spends time trying
to come up with nicknames for DeSantis, including
allegedly, Meatball Ron.
I think that's because of the Santas, his
physical appearance, although I'm not totally
sure.
Donald Trump posting some triggered messages
to South Central, starting with, quote, All
of the fake news is reporting that I spend
large amounts of my time coming up with a
good nickname for Ron to Sanctimonious, who
is obviously going to give the presidential
thing a shot.
They are all 100% wrong.
I don't even think about it.
A very unimportant subject to me.
This is the evidence that Trump is obsessed
with Ron DeSantis.
Trump saying, I never think about Ron DeSantis
or his nicknames.
To me means he thinks about Ron DeSantis absolutely
all the time.
And then weighing in about the polling, some
of which really has Trump doing very poorly
compared to Ron DeSantis.
Trump saying, quote, Doing great in poll numbers,
leading all Republicans by a lot.
Also leading Biden by a very wide margin,
which means that our weaponized in Justice
Department, local DA's and attorney generals.
Oh, come on.
It's attorneys general.
Attorney generals, Trump writes, will step
up their illegal and unprecedented attacks
in order to disparage me with false bull and
statements in the hope that I will be damaged
enough to allow a rhino or Biden to, quote,
slip through the cracks.
But be careful.
The American people get it and don't like
what they are seeing.
Maga.
So this is a very interesting time for Trump.
He knows that the Santos's numbers are very
good for a guy who hasn't announced anything.
But if he spends his time attacking a guy
who isn't even running, it looks very weak.
Trump wants to be Alpha, and his followers
believe him to be alpha to some degree.
As funny as that is.
But Trump must realize if he does spend a
lot of time going after a guy who isn't even
actually running against Trump, it is kind
of pathetic.
It is weakening, it is disgusting and kind
of kind of lame in a way.
So he's going to have to figure out what to
do.
Just as interestingly is that if DeSantis
is going to run against Trump, DeSantis has
to figure out when and how to attack Donald
Trump.
And I want to talk
about
that next.